you love name dropping you love the
celebrities love it I think next to me
the most mentions in your book is about
John Mayor I am in love with John Mayor
we are in love with each
other when you get out to LA how do you
even function like did you know like how
do you get an apartment how do you what
do you do I had a couple friends from
from school that were out here doing
various jobs and gigs and what have you
kind surviving the one person that I
knew that had a had a Hollywood career
was Paul Rudd who I knew from back in
the Midwest and you know Paul had the
long Michael Hutchins hair he had the
cool Duran Duran jacket like I it was
like he was everything that you thought
the cool guy from college looks like in
1988 and he had he had just done
clueless and he had just done uh I think
he was going to go do Romeo and Juliet
so like he was on his way way we knew
and he was nice to you in other words he
hadn't adopted a star attitude like [__]
absolutely totally like well man it's
great you're coming out that's awesome
and I remember saying to him just like
look dude I'm not going to like blow up
your spot you know all all I need is one
phone number just give me one phone
number of somebody that I can call that
can be helpful in some way and he did he
gave me the guy who was his first
manager he said call him he knows
everybody and I sat in a room with this
dude for like 3 hours the guy just
talked and talked and talked and I was
like I guess this is a good meeting I
don't know this is just is like a whole
thing but I ended up getting an agent
out of that and then uh and then I ended
up going on a million auditions and not
getting any of them what a generous guy
you know I don't know if I like if you
showed up at my door and you're like hey
just give me the name if someone help me
out here and I'm like [__] this guy he's
a good looking dude I don't need he's
going to be he's going to I don't need
him doing well competition yeah I don't
know you know Paul Paul's always been
that way and he um throughout my career
in life has been you know we've been
friends for Going on 30 years now he
told a great story I guess you've heard
it a million times but he was a DJ Joe
Buck who's also a very good friend of
ours Joe Buck and I went to one of
Paul's gigs in the whatever early '90s
to pick him up cuz we were all going to
go out and have a have a night and so
there's
some 13 now whatever
47-year-old woman who most likely still
lives on the west side of Los Angeles
who had at her Bar Mitzvah Paul Rudd Joe
Buck and John
Ham and was blissfully unaware of all of
it and it was yeah I mean that's that
was his and we were jealous of him
having that job that was a good paying
gig what was his then he had a character
Donnie the dweeb he would do this dance
called the Dork dance that that became a
as you as you most most likely know with
like uh that that circuit is fairly
small so then if you have any kind of of
of juice on that thing it becomes like
well you got to do the Dork dance and
then it's a I think he ended up charging
more for it I mean it was like you know
if you want the dance then it's going to
be another you know 50
bucks you love Andy I love Andy somebody
asked me the other day how long have you
known Andy and because I've known so
many of my friends for so long I keep
thinking he's my new friend but then I
recalled oh wait I was pregnant I was
really I had terrible morning sickness
and then before I was like oh no he's
not he's my new friend but it's we're
working
on 25 26 years now a real friendship and
we've come a long way in the beginning
we kept bumping into one another and we
had mutual friends but it wasn't a
friendship that was easy do you know
like when you have somebody new in your
life and you're drawn to them but you
wouldn't ask them out alone but then
eventually we were going to the theater
he would come to the theater with me I
drag him to a theater or a restaurant
Deep in Chinatown that he'd try to
understand but those are those kind of
experiences that eventually you're in a
room with him and you don't have to talk
and he's that friend that's real you
know and it just changes I was talking
to Andy last week about this on the air
he told me he's building a house next
door to yours I said you know what leave
the woman alone wait for her to invite
you over I mean I said Andy what are you
standing on the deck waiting to see if
Sarah's out there and then you you know
like I could see him sitting out there
all day it's thrilling and my daughter
is going to babysit for Ben oh wow she
already has actually yeah no it's not a
an an annoyance it's like a kind of a
bonus like some kind of wonderful thing
that happened yeah I don't know I
wouldn't do well with a a famous person
in my you because I'm so [__] up that
I have to be I feel like you're not I
have to be the most famous person like
I'll I'll trust me when I tell you I'm
[__] up you know what I mean like like
like I was walking uh Jimmy Kimmel will
come over my house and we'll go for a
walk or something always throughout the
years that I knew Jimmy early on there
was no question when I was walking with
him everyone came up to me and wanted to
talk with me and would carry on and want
a picture with me and I I loved it
because let him let this guy sit and
watch my fame and then Jimmy show caught
on and he's on Late Night tele all of a
sudden walking with him and people are
hey Jimmy and I was like oh boy oh I got
to get rid of this guy I want him out of
here my life I'm not walking around with
oh no she's going to
joke no seriously I mean Sarah I I don't
want you need to stop she's Ching like I
you know I don't got get I love you but
I'm not walking around with
you this act that you guys have evolved
into could only happen between two great
friends I am just tickled when you guys
are are on talk shows together and you
start going back and forth and there
these great lines about uh Steve ping I
forget what the hell was it the show is
like Steve at the urinal it streams for
minutes I mean these are fantastic how
much time do you guys spend thinking
about each other and writing um uh
horrible things about each other how
does it work from a technical standpoint
you know we used to have a joke that you
know we we tried it on Tom Hanks and he
said oh my God that is so so funny the
joke was this I would open with it i'
say I love working with Marty on stage
because he understands the concept of
640 now Tom Hanks is like laughing his
head and we used it like three times and
it just didn't play like we thought it
would Marty you say hanging out with
Steve is like Deliverance because it's
all fun in games until the banjos come
out that that line is so great I mean
the back and forth between you two this
Bromance whatever it is that's going on
even the two of I hate to hear that but
go ahead but it is a bro you two have
never seen each other nude or have you
um I'm I've not not from the waist
up I've I've only I've only seen Marty
nude through people holes I see you in
touch with Lauren Steve oh yeah is he a
better friend to you than Marty or is
Marty your best friend well I see Marty
Moore Lauren is very very busy yeah who
was the best man at your
wedding was it was it you no it was
Lauren it was
Lauren I was a
bridesmaid you and Adele are real close
huh I mean like crazy close yeah we met
when in Cardiff years ago on a show that
was on channel 4 in England called T4
transmission this is like before even 19
that album 19 was a huge hit this is so
early and
we yeah we hit it off really well and
then my wife is good friends with some
of her childhood friends and that kind
of reconnected us but we'd keep bumping
into each other stay very close and then
you know we have we have uh photos in
like our first apartment in London Jules
and I of like Adele holding our son when
he's like 3 weeks old like it's it's
it's a deep sort of family connection
it's and and I just love her must be a
really freaky feeling when someone you
know you kind of knew and you know you
were hanging out with her she's your
friend and then all of a sudden that
album breaks big and her career is like
bigger than anyone I couldn't have been
less shocked I couldn't have been less
shocked I oh my god well that's that's
how that's how I went up to it and I was
like I think she I I I went up to her
and I was like um because she has the
cover of Make You Feel My Love on that
album and it's as good a cover I think
like I'm always of the feeling that like
how can any cover version be better than
the original because it couldn't exist
without the original but I think there's
a couple that come real real close like
Amy win house is Valerie James Blake's a
case of you and Adele's Make You Feel My
Love and it's extraordinary and I just
it's so clear and what's amazing with
her is there is this there is this
seismic gap between the artist and her
and spend enough time with her
personally you could forget I forget
like and then she'll just sing along to
something and you're like oh my God I
mean I think she is a
generational talent I think and it I
couldn't be less shocked were you
nervous hosting Saturday Night Live when
you're seven years old no I loved it and
Robin Williams came with Steven
Spielberg and they were there for me on
that show yeah why because they felt
like wow there's a seven-year-old girl
on live television maybe she needs uh
some Stephen was there as you know like
a nurturing father to make me feel like
I was you know I had my support system
around and he brought Robin to you um I
think well they were obviously hanging
out at the time and then Robin couldn't
know the world better of comedy and
television so you know they came in the
dressing room and would just give me pep
talks and what would Robin say listen
kid this is how you do it or or uh just
be calm out there I mean he was just
really nice and supportive and I was
freaking out cuz Mor was in the dressing
room and I was like Wow but isn't it
dangerous when you're a little girl and
all of a sudden uh you're on a movie set
like you were let's take ET which is
like the biggest movie of all time but
you start to confuse like Steven
Spielberg as your sort of surrogate
father oh yeah I latched right on and
really that's even dangerous because
Steven Spielberg as much as he might
like you personally you were a commodity
you were somebody who made money and you
did a great job in ET but at the end of
the day's not like that no could you
really trust him oh God yes that was the
thing my karma was great taste in people
but isn't it sad when you look back at
it you had to look towards Stevens
Spielberg the producer or director of
the movie for a father figure what who
better is it a good thing yeah it is a
great thing and by the way but didn't it
Crush you when he wasn't available to
you when Steven Spielberg becomes your
father figure and he's not really your
father and then you go where's Steven I
need him he was never unavailable to me
even at your lowest one I just saw him
the other day I just booked a dinner to
be with him and his wife on November
19th I mean we're still but even when
you go to rehab and you had the problems
with drugs and you were confused didn't
face him I actually was like just give
me a minute I don't want you to see this
and I think that's how children are
supposed to feel towards their parents
you're not supposed to be proud of your
bad behavior in front of them you're
supposed to feel shame so I was glad he
made me feel that way and then we you
know I got older he' I'd walk in with
red lipstick he'd be like can you just
take that down a little bit when I was
like 12 and you know when I was on the
cover of Playboy he sent me the blanket
it was like a famous story and his
production design team covered me up in
the magazine we also well he he sent you
a blanket and he said uh cover up yeah
exactly but he you know but would you be
hurt when he would go on and make all
these other blockbuster movies and he
doesn't put you in them did you start to
confuse that at all oh God no I care you
understood the business oh God yes how
old were you when you were on an ET six
and yet you had an understanding of the
business CU a six-year-old might say why
isn't Steven still in my life why am I
not on the next movie set with Steven
Why is he abandoned me absolutely and he
didn't I was on the color purple and
Raiders of the Lost Arc and you know I
would get to get dressed up in costumes
and like I'm actually in some of those
movies in the background I'm not kidding
when your mom picks you up gets you out
of Baltimore sends you to um the School
of Arts yeah you meet Tupac Shakur no I
met Tupac at Baltimore School for the
Arts we went to high school together is
that and you you you were very close
with Tupac Shakur yes and Tupac Shakur
wasn't the Gangsta that that we all
think he was right I remember his mother
was a black panther yes and he had a lot
of uh black panthers s of raised by the
Black Panthers and all that uh but he
was a revolutionary without a revolution
if that makes any kind of sense so then
that and that that kind of energy just
transferred to a whole another whole
another thing and don't you believe at
that time he was in love with you
because he would write poetry about you
you know I think it's so funny cuz now
being older I I have more of an
understanding of of of what that was
between us because you know when you
have two young people have very strong
feelings but there's no physical
chemistry between us at all and it
wasn't even just for me you know it was
him too I mean don't I mean you know
there was a time when I was like just
kiss me let's just see how this goes and
when I tell you it had to be the most
disgusting kiss for us both why explain
that to me because it was so platonic
the relationship I think you know the
only only way I can put it is just the
higher power just did not want that
because I feel as though if Pac and I
had any kind of sexual chemistry we
might have killed each other because we
were both so passionate and you know we
we love deeply I mean it was hard enough
just with us being friends we had a very
uh volatile relationship um and did you
recognize him is a great talent at that
point did did was it his poetry it was
his poetry it was his personality I had
never in my life uh met a person likeis
he had so much Charisma and he didn't
have he was he was poor I mean Pac was
poor when I met Pac he owned two pairs
of pants and two sweaters and that's it
were you shocked when he achieved the
degree of Fame that he did absolutely
not really I knew that was going to
happen I mean for both of you to become
famous out of the shitty neighborhood in
Baltimore is almost impossible it is
it's crazy and he used to tell me all
the time he was like Jada you're a
superstar he's like you're a superstar
he didn't say it about himself he didn't
say it about himself no he didn't but he
used to say it about me and I you know
and he went to LA and no he went to um
Oakland he went up north and things
started jumping off for him and it it it
really happened for us both at the same
time but then as you go off to LA and
pursue a career and he goes off doing
his thing you guys are not friends he he
went to jail he went to jail and you've
you've said when he went to jail for the
first time he called you after that and
that he changed jail changed him well it
wasn't there was there was a lot of
things that transpired once he went to
jail was really once he came out right
that he you know he he changed quite a
bit which changed him or just coming out
of jail no no no no no Jail jail jail
was was uh was a very uh difficult
experience for him and um and of course
we were on two sides of the of the
spectrum and you know Pac and I have
always had very intense
conversations uh arguments and you know
if we disagree with each other we
disagree hardcore and we had a very
hardcore disagreement and what was the
disagreement what what was the what was
the thing that broke you guys up in
terms of a friendship um I just wasn't
in agreement with the direction that he
was taking taking and I just told him
that you know it it was a a destructive
Direction scary a scary Direction a very
scary Direction and and he felt as
though you know I had changed I got
Hollywood I you know right you had gone
soft I gone soft right and I understood
all that you know and looking back now I
totally
understand where Pac was because at that
particular point in time that mentality
was part of his survival for that moment
and it was actually a mentality he
started to come out of before he was
murdered right and and so you hadn't
spoken to him for a couple of years and
and the point I'm getting at is that
when he was murdered you probably felt a
lot of guilt that you hadn't been in
touch yes or or were you guilt-free
because you said to yourself well listen
I couldn't go in that direction I didn't
want to be friends with someone who was
getting so hardcore angry you know I
don't think I was guilty as much as I
felt just sadness you know for not
having you know just the opportunity to
tell him that I loved him
but I know he knew that you know because
it wasn't the first time that we had had
a bad argument and had stopped speaking
and all that I mean that was kind of a
constant in our relationship so I didn't
really look at it as um you know a
reason to feel guilty but I I it
definitely taught me a lesson which is
life is too short do not is like do not
let disagreements stand in between you
and people that you love and care about
I can tell you're really emotional about
him I mean you're crying I mean when you
think of him you have tears in your eyes
you know I love him yeah yeah terrible
ending it was really tragic but you know
what he he left a very strong and
powerful Mark I mean people are still um
you know inspired by him so he did his
work you love name dropping you love the
celebrities love it I think next to me
the most mentions in your book is about
John Mayer I am in love with John Mayor
we are in love with each other but you
guys even go on like camping trips
together into the I mean swear in your
children's lives there's never been
anything sexual between you and John May
yes I do I swear you swear yeah oh okay
all right yeah is there a chance you
will lose people in terms of friendships
because you are a little bit too chatty
no I think I'm good I think with
John I've said to him many times last
year you know I'm writing a a book I'm
writing a diary he does come up a bunch
regarding Journey regarding that Feud I
was in I think he said to me and I put
it in the book uh he said to me never
get into a feud with an 80s rocker he
he's had a few and he said they're
brutal and they never kind of let go
Sarah Jessica listens to radio Andy a
lot and I'm surprised by the amount she
listens and she often will say to me
that she is so surprised how transparent
I am on the radio about what I'm doing
and what I'm thinking and who I'm seeing
and I and sometimes when she says that I
wonder uhuh did I say something about
you that you're pissed about but she's I
think she would tell me well you see in
the book you when you decided to rent a
house out in the Hamptons it had to be
next door to Sarah J par no that's not
true no it didn't say I didn't say it
had to be next door to her I said it was
next door to her I said I was all the
places in the hamping you went next door
to Sarah wona Woods last summer if you
get the good times reference I are you
Buzzy with your success when you're next
door to Sarah Jessica Parker you come on
I see this smile you can barely contain
yourself you love it I'm not no I'm not
did you stop over friends with her for
25 years almost but to be friends with
sah Jessica Parker I would say the first
five years of our friendship I would
look at her and I would say every time I
got an email from her and every time we
were out to dinner I was like oh holy
[__] I really was I was I could not
believe it and this was also the heest
sex in the city and I'm like I'm I'm
like out with Carrie Bradshaw right now
this is the coolest it does not actually
get cooler than this in my mind and it
was true but it was real I mean I really
was like this is It's I'm still
titilated by our friendship but I've
gotten over the excitement of the
newness of it and the um oh you know I
can't believe this I mean at some point
20 something years into a friendship you
kind of you digest that it's
there